oh i love the smell of rain we don't
typically get that in the desert but
during this time of the year it's
monsoon season and this is from kathy
artuzo
sent to us to our newsroom she's down in
seven hills where we had some pretty
good amounts of rain i'm going to show
you how much they've got there in the
southern neighbors in just a bit right
now that we're going to start off with
our radar because that's where all the
action is at right now we're going to
zoom in neighborhood by neighborhood
down to street level this is in the
southwest part of the valley there's a
215 there's durango right there you've
got a pretty good cell producing some
rain no reports of flooding no weather
alerts have been issued but this is also
producing some lightning and very strong
winds along with that too we've been
watching those neighborhoods of the
south because anthem and seven hills
you've had some pretty good rain along
with silverado ranch the latest on those
neighborhoods right now there's anthem
right here there's your streets you also
getting some rainfall at this hour too
no reports of flooding there but again
this is producing some lightning so
please
head indoors until that storm passes as
far as weather let's go thankfully no
weather alerts have been issued for
southern nevada however those of you
just north of kingman we do have a flash
flood warning issue there due to some
heavier rainfall currently outside 99
degrees yeah the temperatures have
dropped due to the rain but look at your
humidity up to 30 percent your dew point
at 63 degrees chances for storms still
around for tonight tomorrow could be
slightly drier in some neighborhoods but
then we're bringing back the heat we'll
talk about all this and more coming up
in your weather now forecast